supongamos que tenemos una variable
aleatoria continua
y queremos construir la función de
densidad de probabilidad de esta
variable a thor ya continua entonces
pues podemos empezar por dibujar la no
entonces saber empezamos aquí poniendo
en el eje de las x todos los valores que
puede tomar la variable aleatoria x y en
el eje y vamos a escribir los valores de
la función de densidad de probabilidad y
bueno digamos que x es una variable
aleatoria positiva y entonces para todos
los valores menores a 0 lo que hay aquí
está el cero dentro de los valores que
puede tomar x la función de la densidad
de probabilidad toma el valor de 0 ok
entonces aquí está nuestra función de
ansiedad para este pedazo y digamos que
x es una variable aleatoria uniforme
entre 0 y 5
o sea que toma cualquier valor entre 0 y
5 con la misma probabilidad y pues eso
también quiere decir que para cualquier
valor mayor a 5 la probabilidad de que x
toma ese valor es 0 o sea x no toma
valores mayores a 5 por lo tanto la
función de densidad probabilidad también
va a ser cero en este pedazo
porque hay donde este pedazo se sigue
así a todos los reales a la derecha y
este también se sigue a todos los reales
a la izquierda bueno ahora también lo
que nos falta ver es valores toma la
función de densidad de probabilidad de
la variable aleatoria x entre el 0 y el
5 pero bueno como x es una variable
aleatoria uniforme o sea toma los
valores entre 0 y 5 con la misma
probabilidad entonces tienen que ser una
función de densidad de esta forma que
hay una línea recta
bueno aquí en este dibujo no me quedo
muy recto pero si se entienden ahora muy
importante el cero si es uno de los
valores que puede tomar x por lo tanto
en esta gráfica que hay una bolita y
aquí hay un como espacio vacío lo mismo
sucede país 5 en esta gráfica aquí hay
una bolita y aquí hay un espacio vacío a
ver entonces esta es la función de
densidad de una variable aleatoria
continua uniforme en el intervalo 0 a 5
incluyendo al 0 y al 5
y ahora la pregunta es a qué altura está
esta barra para resolver eso lo que
tenemos que hacer es recordar que la
probabilidad de que x tome cualquiera de
los valores que puede tomar tiene que
ser a fuerzas 1 ósea y 100 por ciento de
probabilidad de que x tome alguno de los
valores que toma y en el caso discreto
tenemos aquí algunos valores que x
podría tomar y nada más sumamos la
probabilidad de que hay que tomar a este
valor más la probabilidad que tomará
este otro y así pero ahora como x es una
variable aleatoria continua no sólo
puede tomar el valor de uno o dos o tres
o cuatro o cinco sino que también puede
tomar por ejemplo 3.14 15 92 65 blah
blah blah blah blah o sea puede tomar el
valor de pi o también puede tomar el
valor 2.71 puntitos puntito a puntito
puntito a puntito o sea el valor de él
y x puede tomar cualquiera de los
valores que está en medio okay puede
tomar una infinidad de valores y además
es una infinidad innumerable y están
todos así como que pegaditos entre ellos
justo porque x es una variable delator
ya continua y bueno cuando tenemos este
tipo de variables aleatorias continuas
cuando queremos considerar todos los
escenarios en los que x toma cualquiera
de estos valores por aquí y queremos
sumar todas esas probabilidades lo que
tenemos que hacer sólo porque x es una
variable aleatoria continua es integrar
que es una especie de suma entonces la
probabilidad de que x caiga entre el 0 y
el 5 en este caso es la integral entre
el 0 y el 5 de la función de densidad
ósea el área bajo esta curva ok
todo este pedazo todo este rectángulo de
área
y entonces saber la probabilidad de que
x tome cualquiera de los valores que
puede tomar necesitamos que sea igual a
1 ahora la integral de esta función de
densidad en los intervalos desde menos
infinito hasta el cero es cero porque la
función de densidad aquí vale cero y lo
mismo sucede para la integral de la
función de densidad desde el 5 hasta
infinito entonces lo único que nos queda
es cuánto vale la integral de 0 hasta 5
de esta función de densidad y como es un
rectángulo digamos por el momento que
aquí vale h entonces esta integral esta
área bajo la curva vale vale la longitud
del intervalo por la altura o sea 5 por
h y necesitamos que eso sea igual a 1
porque necesitamos que la probabilidad
de que x tome cualquiera de los valores
que puede tomar sea igual a 1
necesitamos que la función de densidad
sobre todos los reales integre 1
entonces h tiene que ser igual a un
quinto
esta línea tiene que estar a una altura
de un quinto y bueno ya que tenemos esta
función de densidad definida de esta
forma como la función de densidad de una
variable aleatoria uniforme entre 0 y 5
pues vamos a calcular algunas
probabilidades no déjenme borrar esto
para obtener más espacio y bueno
empecemos por calcular con la
probabilidad de que x sea mayor o igual
que 1 y menor o igual que 2 ya que la
probabilidad de que suceda eso entonces
lo que tenemos que hacer es ver qué
valores sobre esta recta hacen que
suceda esto y bueno para que que sea
mayor o igual que 1 o menor o igual que
2x tiene que estar en este pedazo no en
este intervalo y entonces el área bajo
la curva en este intervalo a todo esto
es la probabilidad de que x caiga en
este intervalo o sea de que x sea mayor
o igual que 1 y menor o igual que 2 y
bueno lo que tenemos que hacer es
calcular cuánto vale esta área y pues
tenemos una base de 1 de largo y una
altura de un quinto entonces esto esta
probabilidad es igual a 1 por un quinto
o sea un quinto
y bueno veamos otro ejemplo de estos por
ejemplo calculemos cada la probabilidad
de que 4 sea menor o igual que x que sea
menor o igual que 4 más un tercio ok
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
fijarnos en que x tiene que ser mayor o
igual que un cuarto
y además tiene que ser menor o igual que
cuatro más un tercio o sea por aquí más
o menos no entonces lo que nos interesa
es cuánto vale el área bajo la curva o
sea bajo esta línea sobre este intervalo
o sea nos interesa esta área lo padre es
que esta curva es una línea recta
entonces el área bajo esta curva va a
ser simplemente un rectángulo que se
puede calcular muy fácil multiplicando
la base por la altura la base aquí en
realidad pues es cuatro más un tercio
menos cuatro o sea un tercio y luego
tenemos que multiplicar por la altura
que sigue siendo un quinto
entonces un tercio por un quinto
es igual a y esta es la probabilidad de
que x caiga en este intervalo entonces
hagamos algo un poquito más interesante
pero pues tenemos que borrar un poco
para hacer espacio y no es que lo que
hayamos hecho antes no haya sido
interesante pero pero esto a estar
todavía más interesante a ver calculemos
con la probabilidad de qué
x sea mayor o igual que 2.9 sea menor o
igual que 3.1 que entonces nos tenemos
que fijar aquí por aquí está el 2.9
bueno de hecho está un poquito más cerca
por acá y por aquí está el 3.1 entonces
tenemos que calcular el área bajo la
curva sobre este intervalo
seguro ahorita ustedes pueden decir
rapidísimo cuánto vale pero vamos a
hacerlo un poco más detallado a ver aquí
ponemos 2.9 y aquí está 3.1 y está este
es el rectángulo que pusimos una lupa y
lo estamos poniendo por acá y aquí
entonces estaba se vale punto 2 key que
también es un quinto no y esta altura al
igual que todas estas alturas es de un
quinto
entonces la probabilidad de que x tome
algún valor en este intervalo es de
punto dos por un quinto es el área de
este rectángulo y punto dos es igual a
un quinto entonces tenemos un quinto por
un quinto que es igual
un 25 a bolt y claro aquí entra la
pregunta de y esto porque es más
interesante que lo que estábamos
haciendo pero ahorita es donde se
empieza a poner más interesante aunque
ahora calculemos la probabilidad de que
aquí sea mayor o igual que de 2.99
y menor o igual que 3.0 1 entonces por
acá lo que estamos haciendo es reducir
el tamaño de la base y aquí está el 3
justo en medio entonces 2.99 estás súper
cerca del 3 más cerca que 2.9 y 3 puntos
0 1 también está mucho más cerca del 3 o
keith entonces ahora esta es nuestra
nueva base y entonces esta probabilidad
es este nuevo rectángulo de aquí que me
está saliendo muy chueco
y este rectángulo de qué tamaño su base
pues es de 3.01 2.99 ósea
o sea punto 0 2 a la altura sigue siendo
lo mismo pero punto 0 2 es igual a 1
entre 50
qué es la base y luego tenemos que
multiplicar por la altura que sigue
siendo un quinto y esto es igual a 1
entre 250
y ahora supongo que ya está en que lo
que quiero calcular ahora vamos a
calcular cuál es la probabilidad de que
x este / 2.999
3.001 ok vamos a tomar un intervalo
todavía más chiquito nada cercano al 3
entonces ahora queremos calcular el área
que hay en este rectángulo diminuto
super flaco de por aquí entonces cuál es
su base pues su base es puntos 0 0 2
o lo que es lo mismo 1 entre 500 y la
altura sigue siendo la misma que un
quinto así es que el área de este mini
rectángulo 1 entre
2500 y como se puede ver aquí entre más
chico vamos haciendo el intervalo en el
que dejamos caer a la equis entre más
cercanos a 3 tienen que estar los
valores de x más chica se va volviendo
la probabilidad de que x caiga y
terminemos este vídeo con una última
pregunta cuál es la probabilidad de que
x sea exactamente igual a 313.000 001 ni
2.99 99 9999 a la probabilidad de que x
sea exactamente igual a 3 pues lo que
tendríamos que ver es si aquí está el 3
esta probabilidad ya no es un rectángulo
ya es simplemente una línea recta aquí y
en realidad no tiene algo bueno tiene
área 0 es la probabilidad que una
variable a thor ya continua como esta
variable uniforme entre el 0 y el 5 sea
exactamente igual a un punto como 3
tiene una probabilidad cero aunque
estamos hablando de una precisión exacta
de la probabilidad de que aquí sea
exactamente pero exactamente igual a 30
ok
x hay que recordar que aquí no le
estamos dejando a x está en ningún
intervalo ok x no puede ser 3.000 0001
tiene que ser exactamente igual a 3 y
esa precisión absoluta es la que tiene
probabilidad cero y bueno toda esta
progresión de ir haciendo los intervalos
más chicos y obteniendo valores de
probabilidad cada vez más chicos si nos
indica que esta probabilidad tiene que
ser igual a cero